every day thousands of afghans and
pakistanis cross the border here at spin
baldur since the taliban's takeover of
afghanistan their numbers have increased
significantly among them are members of
the hazara ethnic group from central
afghanistan they told al jazeera that
some afghans are trying to find flights
out of pakistan to other countries while
others are seeking refuge with families
in the city of quetta
further north people appeal to officials
at the torham crossing to be allowed
through some desperately want to be
reunited with family members others are
seeking medical care pakistan says only
those with valid passports and visas are
allowed to cross
the taliban says it's not blocking
people from leaving but afghans must
have the correct paperwork taliban
officials at the border acknowledge
people are suffering economic hardship
in afghanistan but say things will get
better over time
second there is a taliban fighter at the
top crossing he says the country's new
rulers have restored peace and ended
lawlessness
but with trained professionals like
engineers and doctors leaving many
aren't convinced wahid is at the border
to greet his family returning from
pakistan he also wants to go to the
united states
no one can
actually trust them
they are saying because everyone has
has experienced the taliban government
previous uh 20 years before so now no
one can trust them no one can trust they
are saying their words
so i also we
we don't trust on them
the united nations fears up to half a
million people could leave afghanistan
in the next few days and weeks the
pakistani officials on this side of the
border say that they're already hosting
millions of afghans and a further influx
would further pose challenges not just
for aid but for security as well there
are 20 to 25 000 people who cross every
day anyways and many without
documentation which is something
pakistan has been agitating against has
asked again and again for the
international community to help man the
border
after the afghan army withered away the
taliban took over without much
resistance and has made promises of
peace and forgiveness but its next test
is to convince people to stay under its
rule usama javed
border crossing